hello believe nation I am thinking about
writing the top 10 rule success as a
book and I want your feedback on what
you think I haven't make it better so a
little bit of contact growing up this
was one of my favorite books as an
entrepreneur of all time what it
basically does is in like four to five
pages let me see me full of 1 1 2 3 or 5
if you Jimmy me just my favorite
entrepreneur the 1 2 3 4 5 basically in
five pages tells their story what made
them successful and I would read one of
those pages or one of those stories at
least every day just to get me motivated
give me strategies as well as the kind
of motivation to keep going and I begin
a lot of requests from people to say
when are you going to do the top 10
series as a book and I'm wondering it's
now the time it's not a time to do it
and what suggestions ideas feedback you
might have on how to make it a success
I'm thinking something the same lines of
condensing the interviews and the videos
that we have down into 4 to 5 pages on
each entrepreneur telling their stories
sharing their wisdom base to the top 10
but all crunch down into five pages that
see if you can get on the subway or on a
trip or on the beach or if you're
commuting to work or just we sit down at
your desk every morning kind of like
what I did when I was reading this book
and I just want your feedback what do
you think good idea yay nay suggestions
on how to make it amazing awesome your
favorite book of all time let me know
I'd really appreciate your thoughts and
suggestions you guys mean a lot to me
and I really value your English feedback
so please let me know leave a comment
maybe what will happen and if you guys
don't like it if you won't so let me
know guys thank you for watching I
believe in you hope we continue to
believe in yourself you're come in Nina
I mean that Nina loves the spotlight
okay believe in yourself
and and whatever you want were is
Mattias is life here in so much love
much love much love Timo and from the
team okay but seriously let me on the
camera